welcome back well in the last
presentation we described a situation
where you had a bunch of borrowers
they needed a billion dollars
collectively because there's a thousand
of them they need to they each needed a
million dollars to buy their house
and they borrow the money essentially
from a special purpose entity i mean
they borrowed it from their local
mortgage broker who then sold it to a
bank or to an investment bank who
created the special purpose entity and
then they ipo the special purpose entity
and raise the money from people who
bought the mortgage-backed securities
but essentially what happened is the
investors in the mortgage-backed
securities provided the money to the
special purpose entity to essentially
loan to the borrowers and then the
reason why we call it a security is
because not only are these people
getting this 10 a year but if they want
to let's say that you had one of these
mortgage-backed securities and you paid
a thousand dollars for it and you're
getting this 10 a year but then all of a
sudden you think that the mortgage uh
that the whole mortgage industry is
about to collapse a bunch of people are
going to fall and you want out
if you just gave someone a loan there'd
be no way to get out you'd have to sell
that loan to someone else but if you
have a mortgage-backed security you
could actually trade the security with
someone else and they might pay you who
knows they might pay more than a
thousand dollars they might pay you less
but they'll be at least there'll be some
type of a market in the security so you
could have what you could call liquidity
liquidity just means that
i have the security and i can sell it i
could trade it just like i could trade a
share of ibm where i could trade or
share a share of microsoft
but like we said before
this security in order to place a value
on it you have to do some type of
analysis of what you think it's worth or
what you think this real yield or this
real um
the real interest will be after you take
into account people pre-paying their
mortgage people defaulting on their
mortgage and other things like you know
short-term interest rates et cetera et
cetera and there's only maybe a small
group of people who are sophisticated
enough to be able to figure that out to
make some type of models and who knows
if even they're sophisticated enough so
now there might be another investor here
let me make my pen tool work
there might be a whole other class of
investors let me where is the pen
there might be a whole other class of
investors who draw
here say this guy
he would love to kind of invest in
securities but he thinks this is too
risky he'd be willing to take a lower
return
but as long as he was allowed to as long
as he was allowed to invest in less
risky investments maybe by law maybe
he's a pension fund or he's some type of
a mutual fund that's forced to
invest in something of a certain grade
and say that there's another investor
here oh i don't know why my pen keeps
changing
and
and he thinks that this is boring you
know nine ten percent who cares about
that he wants to see bigger and bigger
returns so and there's no way for him to
invest in this security and to get
better returns so now we're gonna take
this mortgage-backed security and and
introduce um one step a further uh kind
of a permutation or i guess a derivative
of what this is and that's all what
derivatives are you probably heard the
term derivatives and people do a lot of
hand waving saying oh you know it's a
it's a more complicated form of security
all derivative means is you take one
type of asset and you slice and dice it
in a way
to spread the risk or whatever and so
you create a derivative asset it's
derived from the original asset so let's
let's see how we could
use the same asset pool the same pool of
loans and
satisfy all of these people satisfy this
guy who wants maybe a lower return but
lower risk and this guy has been willing
to take a little bit uh higher risk in
in in exchange for higher return
so now in this situation we have the
same borrowers they borrowed a billion
dollars collectively right because
there's a thousand of them et cetera et
cetera
and there's still a special purpose
entity but now instead of just slicing
up the special purpose entity
a million ways what we're going to do is
we're going to uh we're going to split
it up
first into three
what we could call tranches a tranche is
just a you know a bucket if you will of
of the asset and what we're going to
call that three tranches equity
mezzanine and senior and these are the
things that are these are kind of the
these are the words that are commonly
used in this industry a senior just
means
these people if if this entity were to
lose money these people get their money
back first so it's the least risk out of
all of the tranches mezzanine that just
means you know next level or middle and
these guys are someplace in between they
have a a little bit more risk but
they still get uh and they get a little
bit more reward than senior but they
have less risk than this equity tranche
equity tranches these are the people who
first lose money
let's say some of these borrowers start
defaulting it all comes out of the
equity tranche so that's what protects
the senior tranche and the mezzanine
tranche from from defaults so in this
situation what we did is we raised out
of the billion dollars we needed
we raised 400 million from the senior
tranche 300 million from the mezzanine
trash and then 300 million from the
equity tranche the 400 million senior
trash we raised from
a thousand
a thousand
senior securities collateralized debt
obligations these are these right here
and they say let's cost say there were
four hundred thousand of these and these
each cost a thousand dollars right
where'd my pen go ten oh i need to make
sure i'm on the right layer
so let's say these cost a thousand
dollars and we issued 400 000 of these
so we raised 400
well my pen messed up again
so we raised 400 million dollars
and let's say we give these guys a six
percent return and this is you might say
six percent that's not much but these
guys it is pretty low risk because in
order for
in order for them to not get their six
percent
the the value of this billion dollar
asset or these billion dollar loans
would have to go down below 400 million
dollars maybe i'll explain i'll do a
little bit more math than another
example but i think i think it'll start
making sense to you for example every
every year we said there's going to be
100 million in payments right because
it's 10
100 million in payments of that 100
million in payments 6 on the 400 million
that's 24 million in payments right so
24 million in payments will go to the
senior tranche
similarly we we issued 300 000 shares at
a thousand uh dollars per share on the
mezzanine tranche this is also a
thousand this is the mezzanine tranche
and let's say they get seven percent
slightly higher return
and these percentages are usually
determined by
some type of market or what people are
willing to get but let's say let's just
say it's fixed for now let's hit seven
percent
so 300 000 shares seven percent these
guys are going to get 21 million dollars
right
so out of the 100 million dollars every
year 24 million is going to go to these
guys
21 million is going to go to these guys
and then whatever is left over is going
to go to the equity to the equity
tranche so the 300 million dollars from
equity
they're going to get 55 million dollars
assuming that there are no defaults or
prepayments or anything shady happens
with the securities
so these guys i don't know why my pen
has stopped working
but these guys are gonna get 55 million
dollars or on 300 million dollars that's
a 16.5
return
and i know you're thinking voice how
that that sounds amazing why wouldn't
everyone want to be an equity investor
i don't know my pen has stopped working
but anyway i'll try to move on without
my pen so you're saying why wouldn't
everyone want to be an equity investor
well let me ask you a question what
happens if
if 10 let's go to that scenario where we
talked before that
20 of the borrowers just say you know
what
i i can't pay this mortgage anymore i'm
going to hand you back the keys to these
houses and of that 20 percent you only
get a 50 return so for each of those
million dollar houses you're only able
to sell it for five hundred thousand
dollars so
then instead of getting a hundred
million per year you're only going to
get 90 million per year
i wish i could use my pen
something about my computer has
frozen
so instead of 100 million dollars a year
you're now only going to get 90 million
dollars a year right and all of a sudden
these guys are not going to be cut off
from this guy's still going to get 24
million this guy's still going to get 21
million but now this guy's
going to get
45 million dollars so he already got but
he's still getting above average yield
now let's say it gets even worse let's
say a bunch of borrowers start
defaulting on their loans and instead of
getting a hundred million dollars
or 90 million dollars per year you start
only getting 50 million dollars in per
year
now you pay this guy 24 million you pay
this guy 21 million or this group of
guys or gals 21 million and then all you
have left is
5 million for this guy
and five million on three hundred
million dollars now he's getting you
know it's like less than a two percent
return so this guy took on higher risk
for higher award if everyone pays sure
he gets 16.5 percent but then if you
start
if you start having a lot of defaults if
let's say um
you know the the return on what you get
every every month goes in half this guy
takes the entire hit so his return goes
to zero percent so he had higher risk
higher award while these guys get
untouched of course if enough people
start defaulting even these people
start to get hurt
so this is a form of a collateralized
debt obligation this is actually a
mortgage-backed collateralized debt
obligation you can actually split do
this type of a structure with any type
of
any type of debt obligation that's
backed by assets so you know we did the
situation with mortgages but you could
do it with a bunch of assets you could
do it with a corporate debt you could do
it with um receivables from a company uh
but the when you read about the most
right now in the newspapers is
mortgage-backed collateralized debt
obligations and to some degree that's
what's been getting a lot of these um
these hedge funds in trouble and i think
i'll do another presentation on exactly
how and why they have gotten in trouble
look forward to talking to you soon